I don't know what kpop is what's the
same for kpop is 90s boy bands and
Groban but being made to sweet happy
cute like colorful ladies balloons
glitter and they're actually like huge
all over the world every single day that
you get relatives these are things that
they specifically designed for each song
so the audience can know it recognize it
and learn it let's start with the
arrogant dance it originated from the
Brown Eyed Girls was popularized by
Psy's gentleman your upper body is
stable while your lower body is having a
sex party that's terrible whiteness is
revealing itself right now
nothing gets ladies like arrogance it's
basically like charades next let's try
electric shock by FX yeah parentheses
experts equation boy fans and girl men
don't do moves like this anymore
[Music]
welcome away all right now the
choreography to a fantastic baby by Big
Bang yeah we were doing a line dance I
would probably think more Street badass
you thought it was all happened at the
glitter show this is a hike [ __ ]
exhausting dance music yeah I'm gonna
teach you the bug dance a craze created
by kata Koreans working in front party
in the back
come on
[Music]
everybody's owned by the same company
for kpop all of Korea is like a Mickey
Mouse Club and this is like a social
studies class and damn cross okay now
we're gonna do sorry sorry from Super
Junior sorry sorry sorry not the Gil
apologetic as we did now you should feel
like you want to have sex with someone
in the camera and it's a group composed
of about ten guys whoa they are more
types in Korea rub your hands together
burn I'm sorry all right get ready for I
am the best from 21 but it's pronounced
21 and also 2ne1
puns are abundant we're definitely the
best rock 21 is not about caring
that's all I think badass [ __ ] that's
right
sexy I don't know if I feel sexy we're
trying to feel sweaty alright guys
here's a tough one
we're doing Ring Ding Dong by shining
Shi for a surfer having sex with a way
so support they can handle sex with that
corner last but definitely not least G
from Girls Generation the style of this
is gonna be everything you thought kpop
was not hardcore not super sexy it's
adorable
there's nine or ten girls this is where
I need to be this is much more of a
workout than the previous guy yes like
girls are way tougher than the Korean
guys it's also hard to hold your smile
ball time yeah because I don't feel
nowadays there are dance crazy
I like find the k-pop artists like idols
because stuff is really hard
the thing is every kpop video there's 12
people and there are 100% in sync and
it's happy yeah I can't be sad what I
like to say it grams is on
what was that one me look they're very
in shape
they're Olympic athletes I had a burger
for breakfast